>> Larry: OKAY.
WITH WELCOME BACK TO THE SHOW.
JOINING THE PANEL TONIGHT IS
COMEDIAN AND ACTOR STARRING IN
THE NEW FILM ROAD HARD, OPENING
THIS FRIDAY, ADAM CAROLLA.
CHEERS CHEER.
>> DIRECTOR AS WELL.
I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE THAT OUT.
A PROFESSOR OF PSYCHOLOGY
SPECIALIZING IN DRUG RESEARCH AT
THE COLUMBIA OF UNIVERSITY,
DR. CARL HART.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: AND THE HOST AND
MANAGING EDITOR OF TV ONE'S NEWS
ONE NOW, ROLAND MARTIN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: AND COMEDIAN AND
COHOST OF VH1'S BIG MORNING BUZZ
LIVE, MICHELLE BUTEAU.
MICHELLE, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
MARIJUANA -- OH, AND I'VE TAKEN
THE LIBERTY JUST FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TODAY I
MADE SOME BROWNIES IN CASE
ANYONE GETS HUNGRY.
I WON'T SAY WHAT IS IN THEM OR
NOT IN THEM.
>> GOTCHA.
>> Larry: JUST HELP YOURSELF
IF YOU WANT TO.
OKAY.
SO.
>> EXACTLY, THERE ARE NAPKINS
THERE TOO.
>> IS THIS BUTTER OR CRISCO?
>> I AM NOT SAYING WHAT'S IN
THEM
>> YOU BAKED THEM?
>> YES, I DID.
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
>> OKAY.
FIRST QUESTION, IS ANYONE HIGH?
LET'S GET THAT OUT OF THE WAY.
>> NO.
LET'S START WITH YOU, DOUG.
YOU ARE FORMERLY A WEED DEALER
AND NOW YOU ARE --
[ APPLAUSE ].
>> AND NOW YOU ARE A NEURO
PSYCHOPHARMACOLOGIST.
>> IT ALMOST SOUNDS LIKE YOU
HAVE TO BE HIGH TO MAKE UP THAT
TITLE. SO YOU SPECIALIZE IN
THIS.
ARE WE READY FOR MARIJUANA TO BE
LEGALIZED NATIONALLY.
>> ARE WE READY FOR THAT?
>> I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTIONS WHEN WE SAY ARE WE
READY?
>> ARE WE READY TO HANDLE THAT?
>> I KNOW IT IS A RIDICULOUS
QUESTION FOR ONE BECAUSE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT MARIJUANA, IT IS THE
SECOND MOST WIDELY USED PSYCHO
ACTIVE SUBSTANCE IN THE UNITED
STATES .. ALCOHOL BEING THE
FIRST.
AND SO PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
SMOKING MARIJUANA.
IT IS NOT A MATTER OF WHETHER WE
ARE READY.
IT IS A MATTER OF, ARE WE READY
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE HOW TO DO THIS
SAFELY, AND THAT'S WHAT IS, THAT
SHOULD BE THE QUESTION.
>> WHAT IS THE WORST THAT CAN
HAPPEN FROM PEOPLE USING
MARIJUANA?
>> LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
>> YOU CLEAN YOUR BATHROOM,
THAT'S IT.
>> CLEAN YOUR BATHROOM REALLY
WELL.
>> CLEAN OUT YOUR REFRIGERATOR.
THAT'S RIGHT.
>> OKAY.
LET ME GET THE SCIENTIFIC
APPROACH FIRST.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
ONE OF THE WORST THINGS YOU CAN
HAPPEN.
YOU SAY WE HAVE BROWNIES THERE.
THEY MAY HAVE THC IN IT.
>> POSSIBLY.
>> ONE OF THE WORST THINGS THAT
CAN HAPPEN IS YOU DON'T TELL US
THE CONCENTRATION THAT IS IN
HERE.
IF IT IS HIGH CONCENTRATION AND
PEOPLE TAKE TOO MUCH THEN THEY
CAN GET INTO SOME TROUBLE, LIKE
INCREASED ANXIETY AND THINK THEY
ARE DYING AND THINK THEY ARE
LOSING THEIR MIND A WIDE RANGE
OF THINGS BUT WE CAN EASILY DEAL
WITH THOSE --
>> BUT ONE BROWNIE IS GOOD, BUT
TEN BROWNIES, THEY'RE GONNA BE
OBESE AND HIGH.
>> CAN I GIVE A TIP TO EVERYONE
>> WHO IS PARANOID? F YOU EVER
THINK YOU ARE DYING, YOU NEVER
DIE.  IT IS WHEN YOU DON'T THINK
YOU ARE DYING IS WHEN YOU GET
RUN OVER BY THE BUS.
>> EVERYONE WHO JUST THINKS THEY
ARE DYING NEVER ACTUALLY
FULFILLS ON THAT PROMISE.
>> WHAT IS IT GOING TO FEEL LIKE
WHEN THIS BECOMES COMPLETELY
SOCIALLY ACCEPTABLE?
>> I AM FINE. THIS IS WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO.  I WOULD LIKE
TO STOP THE DIALOGUE ABOUT POT
AND GAY MARRIAGE AND GET ON WITH
OUR LIVES.
>> ARE THOSE RELATED?
>> IF I ATE ENOUGH OF THOSE
BROWNIES, WE COULD BE MARRIED
I AM SAYING, NO.
>> WHAT I AM SAYING IS THAT WE
ARE DEBATING -- MY MOM WAS A
STONER IN THE SEVENTIES.
WE WERE DEBATING POT
LEGALIZATION --
>> Larry: OH, YEAH.
>> WHAT I AM SAYING IS, THIS
DEBATE HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR 40
OR 50 YEARS NOW.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
>> MORE THAN THAT.
>> 1930S
>> READY TO MOVE ON TO FIGHTING
ISIS.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
>> THAT IS JUST ME.
>> BUT YOU CAN'T MOVE ON BECAUSE
THE LEGALIZATION AND
DECRIMINALIZATION, THAT IS TWO
SEPARATE ISSUES BECAUSE WHEN WE
HAVE TO ACCEPT THE REALITY YOU
HAVE PLACES WHERE MARIJUANA IS
LEGAL BUT LIKE WASHINGTON, D.C.,
WHERE THEY JUST ENACTED IT, YOU
CAN ONLY DO IT IN YOUR OWN HOME,
YOU SHARE IT BUT NOT SELL IT,
YOU CAN'T SMOKE IT IN YOUR CAR,
YOU CAN'T SMOKE IT IN PUBLIC, IT
IS ILLEGAL, EVEN THOUGH THEY
LEGALIZED IT YOU CAN STILL BE
ARRESTED. IN CALIFORNIA IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE WHAT THEY DID
VTHERE IS THEY SAID, IT IS
DECRIMINALIZE AND SIMPLY GIVE A
FINE  AND NOT PROSECUTE.
>> THAT'S THE REAL ISSUE.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT YOUNG
JEWISH MEN GOING TO PRISON
>> Larry: OF COURSE.
>> GOING TO PRISON.
>> Larry: EXACTLY.
>> AND NOW, AND I KNOW WE SPEAK
IN CODE HERE, I AM HERE TO CUT
THROUGH IT.
>> Larry: I WANT TO ASK YOU,
YOUR DAD -- I HAVE LEARNED ABOUT
YOUR DAD IS HAITIAN AND YOU ARE
FATHER IS DOMINICAN AND JUST
READING YOUR BIO GIVES ME A
CONTACT HIGH.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO
SAY BONER TIME.
>> Larry: THAT TOO.
>> YOU MAKE IT SOUND LIKE I
SHOULD HAVE ABASKET OF FRUIT ON
MY HEAD AND PASSING OUT TOWELS
>> Larry: BUT IF YOU ARE THE
EXPERT, WHAT SHOULD WE KNOW
ABOUT THIS?
>> OKAY.
>> FROM A SOCIAL STANDPOINT.
>> DON'T DO IT OUT OF AN APPLE.
THAT IS JUST (BLEEP). GET A
NICE HASH OIL AND YOU
WON'T BE PARANOID AND YOU CAN
ENJOY BETTER CALL SAUL
MUCH MORE WITH A HASH
THAT'S WHAT I KNOW:
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Larry: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
>> DO YOU GET HIGH?
>> LIFE IS GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME.
I AM GOOD.
>> LIFE IS GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME
TOO.
>> Larry:.
>> NO EXTRA ASSISTANCE I AM
GOOD.
>> DOES MAKING IT LEGAL TAKE THE
FUN OUT OF IT?
>> I HAVE EIGHT-YEAR-OLD
TWINS, AND I WANT TO
DESTIGMATIZE THE THING.
\>> BUT A LOT OF KIDS
I MEAN, SOME YOUNG KIDS HAVE
SAID "THE ONLY REASON
I TRIED IT WAS BECAUSE IT WAS
ILLEGAL AND MY PARENTS TOLD ME
NOT TO."
>> SURE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> PLEASE DON'T GET IT TWISTED.
THE LAST THREE PRESIDENTS.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO BEG ME.
>> THE LAST THREE PRESIDENTS ALL
GOT HIGH, RIGHT.
>> THE LAST THREE ADMITTED THEY
GOT HIGH.
>> Larry: RIGHT ON.
>> THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS ALL
GOT HIGH, TOO
>> RIGHT ON, RIGHT ON.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> SO THE POINT IS, IT HAS BEEN
LEGAL, IT HAS BEEN LEGAL FOR,
THROUGH SEVERAL SEGMENTS OF OUR
SOCIETY AND IN OTHER SEGMENTS OF
OUR SOCIETY.
>> LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
HISTORY.
I DON'T THINK EVERYTHING BECOMES
ILLEGAL FOR A GOOD REASON.
OUR TWITTER FRIENDS SENT THIS
QUOTE FROM THE FIRST
COMMISSIONER OF THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF NARCOTICS, THE FIRST
DOES CZAR. THIS WAS IN 1937
>> THIS IS WHAT HE TOLD
CONGRESS.
>> THERE ARE 100,000 TOTAL
MARIJUANA SMOKERS AND MOST ARE
NEGROES, HISPANICS AND
FILIPINOS AND ENTERTAINERS,
THEIR SATANIC MUSIC JAZZ AND
SWING RESULTS FROM MARIJUANA
USAGE.
>> THIS MARIJUANA CAUSES WHITE
WOMEN TO SEEK SEXUAL RELATIONS
WITH NEGROES, ENTERTAINERS AND
OTHERS.
DOES MARIJUANA MAKE WHITE
WOMEN WANT TO
HAVE SEX WITH NEGROES
>> YOU DON'T NEED MARIJUANA FOR
THAT.
>> WHITE WOMEN -- THERE IS
NOTHING WRONG WITH A WHITE WOMAN
TRYING TO GET (BLEEP) WHEN THEY
ARE HIGH.
IT IS THEIR RIGHT.
>> ONE SECOND. YOU POINT OUT
THESE ANCILLARY  STATEMENTS
WHICH WE ALL LAUGH AT, BUT
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION HAD
EQUALLY RIDICULOUS STATEMENTS,
SO AS WE THINK ABOUT MEDICINE
AND PEOPLE FROM MEDICINE
MAKING STATEMENTS ABOUT
MARIJUANA TODAY, RECALL WHAT
THEY WERE SAYING PREVIOUSLY, IT
IS THE SAME SORT OF INANE SORT
OF STATEMENTS THAT PEOPLE ARE
MAKING.
>> AND, LARRY IF YOU ARE LOOK AT
THE DOCUMENTARY
THE HOUSE I LIVE IN.
IT IS ABOUT THE ISSUE OF THE WAR
ON DRUGS AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, IN THIS COUNTRY, WE
TARGETED ASIANS WHEN IT CAME TO
DRUGS, BECAUSE IT WAS A QUESTION
ON TAKING JOBS
>> HEROIN.
>> WE TARGETED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, SO THERE WAS
ALWAYS A CONNECTION IN AMERICA
BETWEEN DRUG USE AND ECONOMICS
AND THAT IS WHY THAT PARTICULAR
STATEMENT IS WHAT IT SPEAKS TO,
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF MARIJUANA, IT HAS
BEEN A WAY TO, JUST
SYSTEMATICALLY TARGET A GROUP OF
PEOPLE AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN
JAIL AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN
WITH METH, A NUMBER OF POOR
WHITES GOING TO JAIL, THIS
MARIJUANA ISSUE NOW FORCES US TO
HAVE REALLY A WAR ON DRUG ISSUE,
A BROADER ISSUE THAT HAS TAKEN
THIS COUNTRY NOW AND NOW YOU
HAVE REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS THAT
ARE REALIZING WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
KEEP LOCKING PEOPLE UP.
THAT'S THE BROADER ISSUE, NOT
HEY CAN I GET HIGH BUT CAN WE
KEEP LOCKING PEOPLE UP
WRONGFULLY AND DESTROYING OUR
COUNTRY AS A RESULT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: YOU WANT TO ADD TO
THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
BUT WE CAN'T FORGET THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF MONEY NOW BEING
MADE.
>> Larry: OH, ABSOLUTELY.
>> LIKE WE POINTED OUT AT THE
BEGINNING ON LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA, SO THAT IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR REASONS THAT IS DRIVING
THIS TOO.
>> Larry: OKAY.
>> IN DC, OF COURSE, THE RACIAL
INJUSTICE DROVE THIS, BUT AROUND
THE COUNTRY, IT IS MAINLY THESE
FOLKS WHO WANT TO GET INTO THIS
BUSINESS AND MAKE SOME LOOT.
>> Larry: LET'S TRANSITION AND
PLAY A LITTLE GAME CALLED
STONED, DRUNK OR SOBER.
YOU HAVE PADDLES IN FRONT OF
YOU.
YOU GIVE US A SCENARIO AND TELL
US WHETHER YOU WOULD BE WHETHER
BE STONED DRUNK OR SOBER FOR THE
EXPERIENCE.
HERE WE GO.
THANKSGIVING DINNER WITH YOUR
IN-LAWS.
>> OH.
>> NO, THAT IS DRUNK.
>> DRUNK.
YEAH.
>> SOBER.
>> I WANT TO REMEMBER EVERY
STUPID THING THAT HAPPENS.
SO I CAN REMIND THEM.
>> Larry: OKAY.
ASCOT SHOPPING.
>> OH, HELL.
>> SOAK EVER.
>> Larry: AND FINALLY THE
NIGHTLY SHOW PANEL.
>> STONED, DRUNK, SOBER.
>>
>> WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>